the iphone 13 lineup was one of the
biggest upgrades apple has had in a
while as a bunch of radical new upgrades
like the promotion display and design
changes reminiscent of the iphone 5 were
introduced with the iphone 14 however it
seems like apple is going a step further
and finally getting rid of the now
five-year-old notch what new changes can
we see in the iphone 14 and is it worth
skipping the iphone 13 let's get started
one the cameras
the cameras are getting a big upgrade as
apple is now shifting to a new 48
megapixel sensor a major boost in
megapixels for its camera as a rumor
suggests that the two pro models will be
equipped with a triple lens rear camera
system with an upgraded 48 megapixel
wide lens and a 12 megapixel ultra wide
and telephoto lens with four times the
resolution of what the iphone is used to
this sensor will offer much crisper
photos with greater detail mid-range
androids like the mi-11 mi11t and even
some high-end ones like the s20 ultra
have been offering phones with camera
megapixels in the triple digits for
years now but there's a reason apple
isn't taking a jump as big as that you
see while a higher number of pixels does
mean the detail goes up it also
drastically worsens the low light
performance the pixels are much smaller
and can't capture as much light as they
used to this means that low light
pictures taken at higher resolution are
noticeably softer and colors aren't as
accurate according to some reports apple
is hard at work perfecting and testing a
new camera system that will shock
everyone into a stupor according to mac
rumors we're expecting improvements to
the ultra wide lens and there's a
possibility the iphone 14 could get a
periscope lens that allows for greater
optical zoom but it's not clear if this
is slated for 2022 or 2023 and the best
part the periscope lens is going to
allow for up to 10x optical zoom yeah no
one's doing it quite like apple right
now on to some even more great news
according to the apple analyst ming chi
quo the iphone 14 will be upgraded from
a six element lens to a staggering seven
element lens in its telephoto camera
moreover the new camera will have 8k
video recording capabilities it's crow's
sincere belief that this 8k video
recording feature will give a great user
experience as the iphone recorded videos
can be displayed on the tv now with this
marvelous resolution we can expect to
create pictures and videos better suited
to apple's new augmented and mixed
reality devices 2. the design change
according to renders and some cad files
recently leaked by reporters it is now
almost certain that apple will get rid
of the notch the new design that will
replace the notch will be a hole punch
and pill-shaped cutout this cutout will
bring back much of the area that the
notch took up and who knows we might
even see a battery percentage indicator
a few updates down the line now the
notch has been continuously getting
upgrades since the iphone x but the fact
of the matter is that in terms of screen
to body ratio the notch just could not
compete with what the androids were
offering phones with in-display
fingerprint scanners and motorized
camera units were offering way higher
screen to body ratios and it seems like
apple has finally decided to up its game
too the new phone is going to have a
thicker chassis now what does that mean
for the latest elegant design apparently
the lenses led flash and lidar scanner
will be lying flush with the rear glass
and let me tell you this sort of
non-protruding camera design hasn't been
seen since the very initial days of the
iphone on top of this the flush camera
might even feature round volume buttons
that are a great throwback to the
buttons from previous iphone 4 and
iphone 5 models now in case you're
wondering no the lack of a notch does
not mean that apple will be getting rid
of face id the pill-shaped cutout is for
the ir scanner needed for face id and
will retain the same amount of security
that apple is currently offering as for
the rest of the design changes apple has
also decided to remove the camera bump
yes you heard that right finally the
ever increasing camera bump is going
away samsung did this with their s22
ultra model and while it does make the
design look a bit bland we are hoping
that apple does it with a bit more
finesse the samsung s22 ultra lack of a
camera housing bump has been replaced by
separate lenses slightly protruding from
the back on the other hand apple is
rumored to be going with a completely
flat glass back much like the iphone 5.
this glass sandwich design is what
people have been looking forward to and
since the iphone x in 2017 this will be
the most significant redesign apple has
had in over half a decade but that isn't
all there is to the new iphone the rumor
mill has been working overtime and clued
us in to some even more radical changes
for example the device will be flattered
due to eliminating the rear camera bump
according to some shaky expectations of
a portless model we might even see a new
titanium casing but apparently apple
could be shifting over to titanium on
the pro iphones in 2022. now we know
that apple has always been way ahead of
its competition in terms of using
stainless steel for its phones while the
other companies have been stuck on
aluminum frames apple has leaped toward
a titanium casing much to the delight of
the fans not only will the titanium
casing provide a lot of protection but
it will also help reduce the phone's
weight so slim light elegant and strong
is the best way to describe the new
iphone 14. the titanium won't help much
with the heat dissipation but for that
apple has been experimenting with a
vapor cooling chamber this technology is
restricted chiefly to high-end gaming
phones and while we've never faced any
overheating or thermal throttling issues
in apple's devices it's still a pretty
significant change that will work out
for the best the processing power of the
a16 bionic chipset will be bolstered so
yeah a vapor chamber cooling system in
the new iphone spell some good news for
all of us as it will help minimize the
effect of faster chips the iphone 14 is
also predicted to come without a sim
tray according to some experts the new
iphone will be getting a great upgrade
that will add 5g connectivity to the
entry-level phone 3. internal hardware
alright so now that we've got the camera
specs and the design out of the way
let's talk about the internals of the
new iphone 14 brace yourselves because
apple fits its new product with pretty
innovative technology this time around
first off the new iphone 14 will be
using a qualcomm snapdragon x65 modem
which is said to be the world's first 10
gigabit 5g modem and antenna system on
top of that iphone 14 is going to have
an a16 bionic chip and the most exciting
part is that the a16 bionic chip will be
based on tsmc's np4 process this means
we can expect to see a drastically
improved enhancement of the five
nanometer family now we have two
different possibilities that are both
credible but the likelihood of one is
more the first possibility is that the
a16 bionic will be built on a four
nanometer chip manufacturing process and
yeah we've all been hoping to see that
since every phone manufacturer has been
trying to achieve that pipe dream but
the more viable possibility is that
there will just be a 5 nanometer chip
this is pretty much a common occurrence
since this will be the third time in a
row from apple so why do we think this
is the most likely option well tsmc
themselves has released these new
tidbits of information so there's a lot
of credibility to it but the perk to the
new 5 nanometer chip is that it will
have an incredibly efficient building
process that's gonna blow everyone's
minds with the performance enhancements
so yeah the a16 is going to be as superb
and powerful as we're hoping in fact
it's going to be 10 more power efficient
than the previous iphone 13 chip this
basically means you won't have to fret
over your battery life because apple has
left every other brand in the dust with
this 10 increase in battery life a
smaller chip with greater efficiency is
a pretty good deal so fingers crossed
that apple will deliver on its claims
and that's not even the half of it folks
because the new iphone 14 will be fitted
with six gigabytes of ram isn't that
simply mind-blowing see you in the next
video till then peace out
[Music]
you